I thought we'd talk about a tweak by some guy called Brady Herron,
who put a picture up saying what's going on here. So I thought we would talk.
That's me. That's you, there's a rainbow there,
but up there there's like these double rainbows up above
Sunday, here's these double rainbows
and then the normal one. So kind of fading out there.
What you're actually seeing is in a very indirect way,
the structure of a molecule,
this is an electron microscope picture of a snowflake, which has six fold,
symmetry, exactly, or symmetry to it.
I don't really want to look at the snowflake.
I want to look up these little hexagons all around.
You see that little ice crystals that form in the atmosphere usually have this
kind of hexagonal structure to them in the 17th century.
Yohanas Kepler the Royal astronomer for emperor Rudolph the second,
as well as the way we astronomers in general, throughout time,
the person who was supposed to be paying him, wasn't paying him.
So he had no money and it was coming up to Christmas and he wanted a present for
a friend of his, and he was kind of walking across Prague in the snow.
The star was coming down and he saw these snowflakes on his jacket and became
interested in the fact that they had this six-fold symmetry to them.
And so he wrote an essay about the six-fold symmetry of snow,
which he gave as a Christmas present to his friend.
And so it was a cheap gift basically, but in that essay,
he talked about why it has the six fold shape.
And he drew this sort of analogy with beehives. You know,
they have the hexagonal structure inside beehives,
and he pointed out that this is the way that you can pack the most into a given
space. The hexagons have this interesting property that they kind of tessellate
together and you'll compact things as closely together.
So we had this idea that it was something to do with the way that the smaller
structures that went in to the snowflake,
what we would now think of as molecules take up this exact and we'll structure
it. Cause that's the way to pack the maximum of the mean.
And indeed that's what's happening.
Water molecules arranged themselves in such a way that they formed a little
Mexicans and then the little hexagons joined together to form bigger hexagons
and so on until you get all the way up to snowflakes,
the smaller structures that happen much more often than snowflake.
So these little exec and all sort of flat-ish hexagonal shapes, and they're,
what's responsible for your halo in any cloud.
You've got these little hexagonal crystals forming and they tend to orientate
themselves flat just because that's the stable thing.
If you think about leaves fluttering down from a tree,
and it's the same in clouds, you have these crystals form.
And as long as there's not too much turbulence in the cloud,
they'll just sort of settle into these orientations.
So you've got a cloud which is basically full of these little hexagonal
crystals, all aligned like that.
And then you've got the sunlight shining on them.
They're not completely transparent.
So they like little bits of glass or whatever.
They haven't got a refractive index to them,
which means that as light passes through them, it gets bent by them.
And in fact, light of different colors gets bent by different amounts.
The bright arc that you're seeing in the image that you took is actually where
the light from the sun is coming in at sort of an oblique angle.
It goes in through the top and then out through the side.
But each time it goes through one of those services,
the path of the light gets bent a bit.
Cause it's parsing from one medium air to another medium lice.
Why does it make an arc? So the reason it makes an arc,
if you look at these things, because they're all aligned, you think about it,
the lights coming in, it said he always different crystals at the same angle,
the vertical,
and then it's passing through a surface which bends that vertical angle a bit.
And then through a horizontal surface, which bends that angle a bit more.
So the light came in and then got bent a bit, then got bent a bit more.
So the light,
instead of coming from over there is now coming from higher in the sky or
appears to be coming from higher in the sky.
But one thing that we haven't factored in is,
although these things are all flat,
their orientation in the other direction is random.
And so that means sometimes it comes out sort of perpendicular to one of these
faces.
And sometimes it comes out at an angle to them that adds another refraction.
So we, the, the amount of the light is bent in the vertical direction is fixed,
but the amount it's been kind of azimuth really around just depends on what
angle of surface it exits through.
So the light is always kind of coming from the same direction vertically,
but gets bent around depending on how it exits from that vertical face of the
crystal. And so that's why you see the light coming from an arc.
So that.
Explains this thing, as I say, which is called a circumstantial arc.
So it's circumstantial cause anything's in the straight up direction and it's
around the Zenith.
They all come from the same direction relative to the vertical,
but different angles around.
So you end up with an arc straight up is up here somewhere and this,
so this is a circle around, straight up. This thing is actually much rarer.
That's called a super lateral arc. And that occurs because,
so although all the crystals that water forms,
at least that sort of atmospheric pressure have this hexagonal symmetry,
they don't always end up as these little flat things.
That's the most common thing,
but another possibility is they can actually grow into cylinders.
Cylinders also tend to orient the tape themselves in a particular direction.
They tend to orientate themselves with their long axis, parallel to the earth.
You've got the light coming in through one of the long sides and then out
through the flat end. But in this case,
you can see that the all kind of being bent around an axis,
which is parallel to the earth rather than perpendicular to the earth.
The thing that you can change in this one is you can rotate that cylinder
around,
which means that the light always gets bent around the kind of a horizontal
axis, but what angle around that horizontal axis,
it gets bent to depends on the orientation of this crystal.
So this thing was around the vertical axis. This is actually a, an arc,
which is around the horizontal axis.
And that's why it's a normal way out for our rainbow.
It was just an axis pointing to you.
And you end up with this arc around that horizontal axis. These are much rarer.
You'll see one of these about once a year, rather than about, you know,
a dozen times a year.
What you're actually seeing here is the crystal structure of ice,
which is fundamentally driven by them, the molecules within it.
And you're seeing different aspects of that molar molecular structure and how it
forms different crystals, making these different colors arcs.
Can you ever get the cylinder one without the hexagon one? I think.
Likely because the flat things tend to fall more commonly than the cylindrical
thing. So in order to get a decent number of cylindrical things,
there's probably an awful lot of land things around this whole thing about
crystal growth and why different crystals form in different circumstances is
really not that well understood.
And there are more complicated structures that ice can form. For example,
it can form a little pyramid or crystal sometimes as well,
which produce a whole nother set of rocks, but they are very,
very rare and the reasons why different arcs form in different circumstances,
it's something to do with the properties within the cloud,
where it's forming the exact state of the humidity and the temperature and all
those kinds of things as to what kind of crystals form. Um,
but it's really clearly quite subtle what it is that ends up for me.
So I saw something reasonably special.
The bright one is fairly common,
but not that often seen because people just don't look up often enough,
but this one, the super lateral art really is a pretty rare phenomenon.
All right. I feel like I've explored enough.
A bit of a lightweight though,
because there are actually rather more spectacular arcs that get seen sometimes
just before Christmas,
this came out on the astronomy picture of the day website of a set of arcs that
somebody had seen. So your arcs are actually these two at the top.
So there's your circumstance at the lock and there's your super.
Paradox. I prefer to call them.
I think they're reasonably, you know, well known at this point.
So I don't think that you get to call them after you,
but there's a whole bunch of different arcs due to different crystal structures,
different orientations that can occur this one.
It's a little bit of a fudge because the reason why the arcs is so spectacular
here is it turns out that just that wind from where this photograph was being
taken, they were making snow for a ski resort,
which was throwing out lots and lots and lots of ice crystals,
which clearly had just got carried off in the atmosphere to create this
spectacular display. But there are actually arcs here,
which have never been seen before. So there's a whole new array of arcs,
which people are now trying to understand. So I got quite interested in this,
on the back of your photo and started nosing around,
turns out there's a really cool piece of software.
That's free to download and play with thing called halo SIM that lets you figure
out what the different arcs are.
So you can actually set up different crystals in different orientations.
You can move the sun around and see what kind of arcs you can make.
And you can see that actually,
a lot of the things I just showed in that picture are here in that arc.
So here are your ox again,
and here are a whole bunch of the arcs related to the ones that were in that
other photo. Is it free software, free software free to download?
Oh, okay.
I want to play temperature that the air that should be with the sun where it is.
And yeah.
Absolutely. That's exactly in fact,
interest in eight is about the temperature of the moon.
The average temperature of the moon is about minus 18 minus 20 centigrade
because the moon doesn't have an atmosphere.
And so that really is the end of the story. As far as the body,
like the moon is concerned.